just after 6 p.m local time on tuesday
the 4th of august
an explosion ripped through beirut's
port
people in lebanon's capital had earlier
spotted a large fire at the port
billowing dark smoke into the air there
were reports
that a warehouse containing fireworks
had caught fire
and several videos of the scene showed
coloured flashes in the flames
videos from the scene suggest there was
one smaller explosion
and then roughly 30 seconds later this
enormous shock
the blast struck with the force of a 3.5
magnitude
earthquake this was the aftermath
windows shattered in buildings across
the city and damaged cars on the roads
near the port
[Music]
this is where the explosion happened
four kilometers away in the saint mar
mahon church
a priest and his congregation were
taking part in mass
the explosion was caught on camera 11
kilometers away
in the dubia marina blast was so big
that it was heard from the mountains
this video from the town of romana 15
kilometers away
shows how far the shockwave reached
it was even heard and felt as far away
as cyprus
more than 125 miles across the
mediterranean
aerial shots show the scale of the
destruction of the port
it reportedly housed 85 percent of
lebanon's supply of grain
which was a strategic food reserve in a
country
crippled by economic meltdown
[Music]
you can see the impact on the beirut
port silos building
before and after the explosion
surrounding the silos were corrugated
iron and steel structures
that have mostly been destroyed these
satellite images reveal the extent of
the damage
this crater was once a warehouse now
it's underwater the colossal force was
caused by the explosion of 2
tons of ammonium nitrate a highly
reactive chemical
which was being stored unsafely in a
hangar
on the port lebanon's prime minister
hassan diab
has promised that those responsible for
the catastrophe
will pay the price